[Musique]
salut gamme alors comme ça on aime les
temps qu est ce que tu crois que c'est
un temps que ça mon garçon world of
tanks c'est un jeu pc gratuit et tout
public
un shooter stratégique du joueur de
temps proposant des combats de qu'un
stand contre 15 banques 10 ans
d'existence
world of tanks est la référence des jeux
de tanks 210 millions de concret et au
moins autant de tanks 40 femmes
différentes
me remplit de trois mois le monsieur est
bizarre non je le monsieur a raison
chérie c'est pas un temps que ça c'est
de la merde tout jeu contient plus de
600 chars customisation dont une partie
étant des prototypes ou des projets qui
n'ont jamais vu le jour
là bas et en cliquant sur le lien
d'inscription tous les nouveaux joueurs
qui se feront un compte recevront un
char près bien eu quelques exceptions de
tirs 5 7 jours ne prévienne pour booster
l'expert en jeu à chaque partie tout 158
crédit et trois chars très violent
emblématique en location pour vie
bataille chacun alors comme ça et en
maths petit bernat salles occupées et
d'avoir tué m'expliquer pourquoi tu
joues avec ce temps tous pourris la
[ __ ] mais la honte la honte quoi
téléchargez world of tanks sur pc le
lien est dans la description
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy grenier autre chose à
faire que veut dire merde je me voir
quoi mais on n'a pas le droit de sortir
ben je sais pas moi allez aussi des
messies fermé ne pas trouver autre mario
land mayhem ampli petit papy tu nous
raconte une histoire à une histoire est
ce que je vous ai raconté la fao
isabelle balkany est devenue
chroniqueuse sur la piste est vraiment
en train de devenir des petits oui c'est
vrai que c'est n'importe quoi alors
plutôt est ce que je vous ai raconté la
pire chose qui me soit arrivée de ma vie
c'était en 2020 la dernière année plutôt
sympa que le monde ait connu cette
époque me faisait appeler g j'habitais
le tentaculaire ville de night city on
l'appeler comme ça parce qu'il y faisait
toujours nuit la nuit est rapidement je
suis tombé dans la criminalité parce que
aucun patron de voulais m'engager j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi
et du coup trois choix de carrière se
sont offertes à moi nomade un petit
criminel du désert veuillez prendre la
partie un coin des rues petites mimines
elle des villes gaz délit par terre ou
corporate un criminel richer puis-je
start 1
atraveo foutez de ma gueule foutage de
gueule par terre je vivais de petits
larcins avec mon bon fauteuil de jacky
c'était un fanfaron jaqee il faisait
souvent le chaud d'ailleurs son surnom
c'était le magicien très vite on est
allé voir un char culotte pour me mettre
des implants
on pouvait tout changer sur une sortie
doc le système immunitaire le système
lymphatique le globe oculaire et tous
les cerveaux tournée avec un système
d'exploitation et voilà s'est installée
vous êtes prêt à partir pourquoi je
m'étais trois heures à me lever tous les
matins
du coup comme ça marche bien j'en ai
profité pour tout faire changer dé
l'homme dans les bras des propulseurs
dans les jambes des nouveaux yeux
j'avais des gadgets dans chaque partie
du corps
j'étais devenu un être totalement
cyberpunk un bercy d'agbar la ville
avait peur de moi et je l'avais peur
d'elle mais j'étais prêt à affronter
tous les défis
il fallait qu'on fasse un gros coup pour
ce faire un hub d'euros dollars voilà on
a retrouvé une grosse mission on devait
dérobé une puce mais tout a mal tourné
on a assisté au meurtre du pdg d'un rat
s'accapare son propre fils devant nos
yeux et les flics pensé que c'était
notre faute
et ce pauvre jacky se retrouve avec un
flingue dans la tête n'ont pas pu une
belle à dont un flingue dans la tête ça
fait encore plus mal
oui oui les objets volés en fait on
avait mis des petits réacteurs dans à
peu près tous étaient bien pratiques
veuillez mettre votre téléphone en mode
avion s'il vous plaît mais je reviens
plus tôt à l'histoire
du coup pour sauver la puce j'ai dû me
le mettre dans le cerveau mais en mon
réveil je me suis senti bizarre mais ça
va deux secondes laissez-moi lui même
miroir j'aimais bien m'entraîner devant
le miroir pour mes cours de théâtre
les émotions c'est ce que j'avais le
plus de mal à maîtriser mais je me suis
rendu compte très vite que à cause de la
puce que j'avais inséré dans mon cerveau
eh bien je n'étais plus seule au réveil
choisie il faut allumer le feu il
fallait absolument que j'enlève l'esprit
dé johnny qui était dans ma tête et que
je prouve que ça n'était pas moi les
meurtriers du pdg d'ares à chaque cas si
je ne vais pas dans les 15 jours sans
esprit allait remplacer le mien et je
serais mort et du coup tu as fait quoi
papilles
[Musique]
je me suis promené pendant cinq mois
c'était cool and night city sacré ville
avec ses habitants qui font du street
art avec de la laque série pleine de
lumière et ces hologrammes du désir
apparaît ces cyber armée c'est faux
handicapés
ces gens qui se pisser dessus ces
oeuvres d'art et ses habitants qui
avaient des difficultés à prendre
l'ascenseur non ça marche pas comme ça
hein monsieur parfois j'aimais bien
suivre les habitants de nice city nommé
les oeufs et vivre leur routine
quotidienne y avait aussi des salles
d'arcade j'adorais aller dans les salles
d'arcade et ne pas jouer
il y avait plein de jeux auxquels on
pouvait ne pas jouer et si tu n'aimes
pas les jeux vidéo il y avait le jeu de
la pouliche c'était un jeu très répandue
d'un accident en fait pour jouer c'était
simple il fallait me mais le bruit des
des double six j'ai gagné mes night city
c'était très connu pour sa débauche
watson were milgaard white dreams
bottom-up marrane rita on pouvait pas
faire trois mètres sans tomber sur des
pubs de qu on se serait cru sur youtube
c'est pour ça que je regardais plus le
thé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore les beats à quoi vous me
raconterez rapport mais tout le monde
avait mal au bras
peut-être une épidémie de tendinites je
sais pas mais heureusement la médecine
avait fait des gros progrès docteur j'ai
une petite douleur au poignet et très
bien vous apprendre un petit doliprane
parce que ça peut faire mal quand je
coupe le bras regardez c'est la nouvelle
tendance du moment
tout le monde aime ça elle et moi qui
venais moity c'est la tipp own sédatives
au président j'avais fait la
connaissance de pâques humour allait
m'aider à rencontrer un à qu'osama qui
aurait pu m'aider à enlever le
constructeur johnny dans ma tête j'étais
aussi aidé par rock était une ancienne
copine à john il ya cinquante ans et qui
aurait je suis allé chercher evelyne qui
était la copine de judy mais elle avait
disparu mais finalement judy m'a orienté
vers brigitte brigitte qui m'a ensuite
aidé à trouver altun qui était l'ex de
johnny dans le passé mais qui était
devenu une ia magnifique sur internet
et puis après il y avait cela la
batterie et mitch la guitare et puis
avait mari ainsi omar sy et tu savais
que tu es d'art oui d'ailleurs en
parlant de se garer il faut aussi je
vous parle des voitures le code de la
route avait été énormément renforcé
tout ça à cause de ces idiots qui
s'amusaient à faire des tonneaux et a
explosé leur bagnole partout
du coup on avait mis quelques règles un
peu stricte par exemple c'était interdit
de doubler les gens peut-être à lui au
début mais j'ai dit pour l'heure rien au
final
j'allais à l'hôpital pour accoucher puis
je me suis retrouvé bloqué là finalement
j'ai accouché dans la voiture mais où
est votre bébé du coup parce que je le
vois pas il est là il a 23 ans
maintenant aller avant ça après les gens
conduisent est de moins en moins on
avait des voitures automatiques
c'était pas très au point les voitures
invisible ça marchait bien par contre et
le meur avait aussi passer cette loi
bizarre qui disait que chaque fois que
vous ne regardiez pas une voiture il
fallait qu'elle change de formes et de
couleurs
au début c'était difficile à mettre en
place mais ça a vraiment relancer
l'économie mais si on aimait les
voitures on pouvait aussi faire des
courses de voitures
c'était très dangereux alors certes tout
le monde se tirer dessus et se tirer
dessus ça empêche pas d'être fair-play à
regarder ils m'attendent
c'est beau un monde qui joue et quand
j'en avais assez des voitures je pouvais
aller me défouler en faisant de la boxe
par exemple ont respecté l'adversaire
pas d'armé blanche pas de fusil juste
des produits dopants un bras
cybernétique et le taf et pendant 20
minutes dans les cours
il valait mieux savoir se battre parce
que night city était une ville très
dangereuse aux mains des gangs les
valentins os6 street les desosseur les
animals que des gens très dangereux il
ya un thé à lausanne
du coup les gens dans la vie il était
souvent un peu nerveux
jacques cartier était dirigée par un
fixeur qui me donnaient des missions il
était vraiment professionnel mais par
contre [ __ ] j'aurais jamais dû leur
lécher mon numéro faire chaud
oui mais voilà déjà d'acheter votre
bagnole arrêté de m'appeler mais toutes
ces missions c'était un bon moyen de
faire de l'argent
tuer des gens je ramassais tout ce qui
traînait par terre et je revendais tout
à n'importe quel marchand enfin dans la
limite de leur argent disponible bien
sûr chéri regarde j'ai fait une super
affaire quatre cendrier deux paquets de
gâteaux et avait invités de patrick
sébastien une bougie fantasy un scalpel
un dvd du petit ourson en a claqué tout
notre poids nos là dedans
pourquoi t'as fait ça je crois que j'ai
un problème c'était facile de faire des
affaires et de gagner un peu d'argent
le meilleur moyen c'était encore de
revendre leurs armes c'est ça qui
rapportait le plus chéri des gars que
j'ai acheté des ramen ça payait pas
beaucoup mais c'était un travail honnête
à l'été ne les enfants amusez vous bien
aller qu'est-ce que je nie on comprend
dans les couloirs c'est dangereux
et de toute façon je préférais les
ventes rejetez pas trop doué avec les
armes déjà j'ai jamais su tenir un
katana correctement n'y avait pas de
police and night city papier
si je vous le dis
on avait beaucoup investi dans les
policiers leur point fort c'était la
discrétion
tu le voyais jamais mais textile volé
par un crime
étupes aux papilles tap est innocenté
pour le meurtre au du pdg taratata
c'est vrai on a oublié et anna qu elle
t'a aidée non fait
et du coup tu est guéri tu vas plus
mourir dans quinze jours annonce je suis
complètement guéri maintenant je meurs
dans six mois j'avais réussi à enlever
de jeu ni de ma tête grâce à son ex
démoniaque
plus les
c'est lui mon pote mais du coup papilles
elle est pas si ni ton histoire
t'as pas honte de nous sortir des
histoires pas fini écouter les enfants
je vous promets que nous faisons
vraiment des efforts ici à la maison de
retraite pour vous offrir des histoires
toujours plus passionnante et
intéressante
c'est cette volonté de communication
honnête et sincère qui vous a fait pré
commander notre histoire et nous vous en
remercions
dès la semaine prochaine nous
rajouterons un nouveau personnage et
nous allons corriger de nombreux
problèmes en travaillant à regagner
votre confiance
mais papy c'est pas une histoire passée
à jeu vidéo dans quoi je vis des autres
femmes d'adjamé content veut tirer hors
d'une rencontre bien sûr mais ce sera
pour la prochaine fois
[Musique]